have you done a lot of podcasts no i
think this is my second one who did that
who's who was the first podcast uh rob
lowe
rob lowe yes right okay and what it did
what did he ask that did anything he
asked
is that was better than you yeah is this
the best
i want to know i just saw recently oh
it's the same we were just talking you
know i'm as good as roblox you are not
as good looking as roblo but you're as
good as roblox i saw you just went to
was it sarah highlands wait what what
what you just told me i'm
not uh that i'm i mean you don't
remember rob lowe how he looks very
handsome and he was like
not him look at this look at this okay
you're handsome buddy and different
handsome roblox like let me ask you
something roblox is like ken handsome
you know like the barbie and ken and i
am like yertle the turtle handsome
[Laughter]
no what do you think
i look like a turtle i think i look like
a turtle
no i do look like a turtle what stop
putting words in your mouth what kind of
handsome is he then
like a mole i like like
like a mole
i'm like a mole like a mole rat like a
naked
i was gonna say i'm more more relatable
kind of handsome you know what's a more
relatable hey like you're not a movie
star
movie handsome not even tv handsome like
in a mall yeah let's keep going stop
putting words in
just like a reality tv handsome you know
it's like reality tv awesome
like ice road truckers
that's reality yes yes like uh
catch what's that
what's the catch the ultimate cat what
is it what is it called
the deadliest catch kind of guys
kind of a little bit more rough you know
i look rough
i've never been i don't know but you
used to with your hair you used to have
all that hair you know now and now you
have nothing yeah but it works i mean i
still think of you with hair you know
when i think of you because to look at
me like this no you know how people
think of you think of someone you see
them kind of yeah you realize you like i
work with me
you've only worked with me without hair
yeah but i knew who you were with hair
but so that was like but you don't want
to picture me like this when you think
of howie no no i mean i don't know i
don't choose to pick how i
see people in my head but now i'm your
little ice road trucker you're like my
ice rods rocker
that's amazing
that's amazing
you're handsome howie and you know it
you have all the fans
oh you're a good actress
you're a good actor you're a liar
no
you know it she is a good actress
[Music]